- [Voiceover] This
square is 1 square unit,
so what is the area of Rectangle A?
The first thing we're told is that
each of these little
squares equal 1 square unit,
and then, we're asked to
find the area of Rectangle A.
Here's Rectangle A, and area
is the space that it covers.
So how much space does Rectangle A cover?
How many square units
does Rectangle A cover?
One way to answer that would be count
how many square units it covers,
except they've covered
up our square units.
So, one idea's we could draw them back.
Say you cover'em up,
we'll draw them back in.
So goin' like this, connect all these,
and then, we should be able
to count our square units.
So we have one, two,
three, four, five six,
seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12.
12 square units.
Rectangle A covers 12 square units,
so it has an area of 12 square units.
But this isn't the only way
that we could've solved this.
We could've also said, we
could've also looked at this
and said, okay, this top row
is four square units long.
One, two, three, four, has
a length of four units.
So that means the top row will have
one, two, three, four
square units inside of it.
And then we coulda looked
over on the side, over here,
and said, well, how many
rows of four will they'll be?
It'll be one, two, three rows of four.
So we'll have this row of four,
and then a second row
of four, and a third.
So three times, we will
have four square units.
There's four square units at the top,
another in the middle,
and another at the bottom.
Three times, we will
have four square units.
Or, we could go even farther than that.
So we coulda done three times
four, or we could look at this
and say, okay, here's one column.
This column has three square units.
It has a length of three.
One, two, three.
How many of these columns
like this will there be?
There'll be one, two, three, four,
'cause our length here at the top is four.
So, this time, four times, we
will see three square units.
One, two, three, and we'll see that
one, two, three, four times.
So, no matter which of these we solved,
whether we counted the square
units like in the beginning,
or we multiplied the side
lengths, the three and the four,
in every case, we're gonna find
that this equals 12 square units.
The area of Rectangle A is 12 square units
because it covers 12 square units.